[Music]
Hey
I'm back again with yoga mama Nica Karan
miss her workout I do so nikka what are
we doing today today we are going to
combine yoga and high-intensity interval
training into a nice sweaty workout so
it's going to be like a stretch and
it'll sweat all right yes so guys you
would get that deep stretch that you
really need at the same time it will
give you the burst of energy I'm excited
let's get started
let's do it that thing has to be on your
mat with your hands and your knees
keep your spine straight eyes closed and
bring attention to your breath breathe
deeply
releasing any tension in your body with
every exhale
[Music]
and with every inhale feeling more and
more relaxed
[Music]
nice long deep breath one more exhale
out and then slowly open your eyes bring
your hands all the way up and stretch
and gently bring your left forearm down
right hand goes up stretch to the side
open your chest and then gently to the
other side
inhale up bring your palms behind you
and we're gonna just lift your hips up
open up your chest here and as you
exhale slowly ring sky from here drop
your thumbs down let's release all the
way down into your downward dog
and again just walk in one place to warm
up your spine lengthen up inhale again
and then slowly weave all the way
forward into your plank pose and with
inhale down into downward dog and one
more time gently forward engaging your
core and with inhale all the way down
and one more time all the way forward
and again all the WIDA good take a deep
breath in again here in downward dog as
you exhale let's slowly walk forward to
the front of your mat from here keep
your left knee bent left hand down on
the ground right hand is reaching all
the way up open up your chest
Oh stretch for your legs
you're right and change the side right
hand goes down laughs and reaching all
the way opening up that left hand good
as you exhale drop your last hand down
keep your knees bent with inhale let's
lift all the way up into your chances
and then slowly all the way up bring
your palms to your chest we're gonna
start up some Sun Salutations to warm up
with inhale hands up
as you exhale swan dive full inhale head
as you exhale step back trickling gently
to chaturanga inhale Cobra and exhale
down with that
breathe in your dander lengthening
through the spine squaring your helps
for three
[Music]
so
[Music]
slowly step all the way forward inhale
head exhale full inhale lift all the way
and exhale prime say chest mean hella
exhales one day inhale and exhale step
or jump into chaturanga inhale Cobra and
exhale down keep breathing
shoulders away from your ears
another three
[Music]
and inhale as you exhale jump respectful
cutter exhale inhale all exhale pants
your chest three more in exhales Wanda
inhale and exhale step or jump and drop
your knees if you want in your
chaturanga inhale Cobra exhale down with
a braid EP four three two and inhale
again as you exhale jumper step for head
exhale full inhale exhale pants your
chest
continue inhale exhale down inhale and
exhale step or jump to chaturanga inhale
Cobra and exhale downward dog
keep breathing spine should be all
straight
lengthening your whole body another two
and mmm hello again
as you exhale step all the way forward
inhale header exhale full inhale
reaching up and exhale palms your chest
and last one inhale lift exhale Swan de
inhale and exhale step or jump into
chaturanga inhale and exhale down with
three four five four three two
and slowly jumper step all the way full
with head exhale full inhale up exhale
promise to your chest how I read every
Sun Salutations gonna move into your
high intensity intervals with inhale one
more time hand exhale Bend full inhale
and from here step to plank fish that's
that with first exercise mountain
climbers from here left and right and
two and three and four
continue and five strong core six seven
and eight nine and ten
good hold your plank four three two one
inhale press it down rest in down
breathe deep not afford
sorry
and let's get ready for exercise number
two bring your left leg forward run your
right foot pointing forward inhale let's
lift into high lunge and from here
you're gonna lift up stretch you're like
all the way pull it and then again go
back into your high lunge
good again inhale lift and kick exhale
down and up and good four and down on
balance five
mm-hmm good and six seven and eight
strong legs nine and ten high lunge hold
breathe bye four three
two and one drop your pants down and go
into your downward duck to rest for five
deep breaths four three two and one
alright let's repeat on the other side
right leg comes full with high lunge
inhale hands up good and from here
gently up and down and to stabilize four
and five lunge six seven valence steady
legs eight and nine and ten hold your
highlight breathe right knee right above
your ankle four three relax your
shoulders - and one times then push into
your downward dog to rest breathe deeply
four three two
and one from here step all the way oh
good lower your hips inhale hands up
we're gonna go to squat jacks hands down
and eat up and two and three four five
six seven eight nine ten and hold maybe
we have house again for free feel the
burn two and one
inhale lift up exhale we're going to go
down stand here rest for lengthening
your spine three two and once you're
gonna lower it and go and our back to
again the exercise her hat go all the
way down lift your legs up can support
with your hands and I'm gonna do leg
raises all the way down and up and two
and above like straight three four
five six seven eight nine and good
stretch your legs up and hold your toes
pointing towards your face breathe for
five four three two and went drop your
knees to your chest let's rest for
another five breaths before we move on
to round two three four three two and
one alright from here let's try to rock
forward and back to go again
forward step to plank pose and you're
going to begin round two hello intervals
all right mounting lengths left and
right three good for call strong and six
seven eight nine and ten
hold your plank four three two and one
releasing your damage a very deep
five long deep breaths three two more
[Music]
one you're going to Highland to the kick
left leg goes forward come up into
Highland hands if good Holly's raising
her inhale let's lift up stretch and
down and stretch and done good and three
and four
give it five six
nice seven and eight nine and ten high
lunge hold weaving DC here another five
losing a rest early four three two and
one release relax in downward dog five
deep breaths if you need a break you
feel free to go down into Child's Pose
dropping your knees to the ground
another three two and one let's repeat
on the other side right leg goes forward
let's the pointing forward Highland deep
breath in inhale and it's stuck up and
lunge with the kick and three balance
for
five six going great seven eight nine
ten and highlight chop breathe deeply
here stretch your legs now there four
three two and comes down down the death
breathing relax all right stretch it out
and Donna duck relax for another three
two one and you're going to move on into
us it's quite jumps jump or step all the
way forward good handle and stop ah
good two three four five six go those
seven eight nine and ten hold hands up
or down and hspeed about in the video
core another three two and one inhale
exhale just release and breathe here
okay you can keep your knees slightly
bent or you can fool your hands up to
you just relax another three two and I'm
here you're gonna go all the way down
into our leg raises just go all the way
flat on the mat bring your hands down
nice eh hasn't straight all the way up
inhale as you exhale lower your legs
down inhale up exhale down just sliding
you about the ground inhale and X good
continue all right not at five and down
strong core and three more to
strengthening your abs and one good last
one there's pointing towards your face
straight legs breathe four three two and
one
drop your knees to your chest breathe
deeply again
stay here I'll rock from set aside to
stretch your back just relax
three two and one
all right now you're gonna get rock
forward and backwards so we can go all
the way up all right yeah and exhale
down head up and from here I step back
in see you're down with good take a deep
breath in and let's bring the left leg
all the way up and stretch let's the
exhale gently step forward ground your
right foot again warrior one inhale
deeply you're gonna cool down at this
gentle stretches holding for a while
three squaring your hips two and one
inhale straighten it as you exhale bring
your hands to the set into warrior two
left knee right above your ankle and
just breathe relax three two and one
from here straighten it left hand
reaching all the way food and down right
hand it look through it to your right
palm read
opening the chest stretching your whole
left in a tie to and slowly lift up keep
your left knee gently ban laughing goes
above just reverse it quickly good and
as you exhale we are going to bring your
elbow down on top of your tie right hand
above your head and just bring it here
and stride gently for if you looked over
to your palm three two and slowly
release and you're gonna bring your
hands down I'm gonna bring your foot
slightly to the left
drop your right knee down okay from here
you're gonna lift up maybe bring in for
slightly closer see the distance here
and gently lean forward I'm gonna open
up the hips look up lift your chest if
you want you can bring your hand up as
well okay really up to you see how
comfortable you are here breathe
[Music]
and one as you exhale slowly release and
we're gonna bring your thumbs forward
you gotta go to lizard pose again you
can try to bring your forearms down see
how it goes don't force it okay if it
doesn't feel ready you can always go a
little bit higher just make sure you're
opening the hip here see what feels
right three another three two and then
slowly release from here we're gonna
lift up and keep both legs straight
inhale lift your head up as you exhale
gently bend forward towards that left
leg stretch it all out breathe again
don't stress about bringing forehead to
your knee just go as far as you can to
and when inhale up and let's go all the
way down into Adama dog stretch your
back releasing any tension in order to
[Music]
anyway let's repeat on the other side
inhale right leg goes all the way up as
you exhale step all the way fold you're
gonna go to warrior one grounding the
left foot hand up I'm just breathing
your warrior one another three shoulders
dropping down two and one
inhale lift up as you exhale it's good
to warrior two
right knee right above your ankle laughs
like all straight breathe relaxing your
shoulders two and one inhale straight it
up maybe bring your feet slightly closer
back reaching all the way forward and
down left hand up into your triangle
again to stretch your whole body open
your chest look up to the chilla
[Music]
breathing deeply through your nose
always connecting with your breath as
you inhale slowly lift up maybe bend
your right knee gently just quickly
reverse good and as you exhale right
from is reaching down all the way inside
of your right foot left hand above your
head in an easy side angle dropping the
hand all the way above your head good
just breathe
one more and slowly release - from here
bring your right leg good down drop your
left knee and again maybe reverse your
left foot slightly to the back Co feels
good inhale lift up as you exhale slowly
lean forward maybe open the knee to the
side lift your chest go through back if
you feel comfortable lift your hands up
and breathe opening your spine three two
and one as you exhale slowly release and
against put your right leg slightly
further to the side bring your both
forearms down if you can and gently open
your right knee in you
please it's worse
remember this kind of poses you
shouldn't push you just sort of relaxed
interviews and always listen to your
body not to strain any muscles
[Music]
okay one more deep breath in as you
exhale out bring your palms down and
again I'm gonna straighten your both
legs bring me slightly closer inhale
head up as you exhale gently bend
forward and just breathe
stretching out all the muscles on your
right leg
good two and one
inhale and gently with exhale step back
into your downward dog again breathe
deeply redundant two more
and wine and gents you drop your knees
down you can just have a quick stretch
and you child suppose that the forehead
down to their ground and relax
[Music]
following your breath releasing any
tension in your body with every accident
[Music]
inhale deeply one more time and slowly
release I'm gonna bring your knees
together alright one more inhale stretch
your hands up gently to both sides and
right and then slowly raise thank you so
that's it guys that's your full body
workout using yoga moves and high
intensity intervals oh my god I am
sweating I was struggling but I feel
really good right now so you have to try
this workout okay those those poses that
requires a lot of holding it's just
painful this is where all your muscles
are working yes I have a reaiiy had a
really good deep stretch and also I feel
my muscles really burning right now so
do try this workout be sure to check out
other yoga sequence with Nika right
there like this video share this video
with a friend and subscribe to my
youtube channel for a lot more work of
videos wreckages and also more yoga
workouts with Nika